oh hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to welcome to the game
please tell me that you can hear me at
the beginning of this video right now
because I have a lot to say I have a lot
of a lot to say I have so much
incredible stuff to start saying so can
you see me and can you hear me is it
good ah lock up the lock jokes it's not
time for locking yet okay you can see me
okay good all right so here is the deal
I have pretty much okay i have pretty
much every resource that i need to be
able to beat this game i know the
strategies i know everything that needs
to be done and they recently patched the
game to change up some of the mechanics
not to really make it easier but to make
it more clear as to what needs to be
done and when so first off the threats
the police are very meticulous about
what they do if you're on the free Wi-Fi
they will come get you after about 10 to
15 minutes no matter what Wi-Fi you're
on you need to hop between each one
every 10 minutes which can get annoying
but not entirely lethal but there's more
benefits to be able to be on another
Wi-Fi then just that makes sense so you
want to basically change every Wi-Fi
every 10 to 50 minutes or if you're on
the WEP Wi-Fi you can change over 20 to
25 minutes which just means you need to
change every 20 but not only is that
better because the the time duration
before the police get you is longer it's
actually faster internet so you can
actually hop between those and get a
little bit of a better connection i'm
not a hundred percent sure about that i
haven't tried it for myself but that is
told and then if you go on the wpa and
wpa2 it's like fifty minutes and then
ninety minutes which would be so much
time that you don't even need to really
worry about it anymore but if you can
get by on just the WEP that is baseline
enough eventually you would want to get
upgraded but it also takes time to hack
them and you only have one night to be
able to do this number two the breather
the breather we've gone through it and
it's pretty simple you just go down the
alley if you hear any you know is behind
you in fact me personally i'm just gonna
go to
every time until I hear steps it wastes
a little time but the safety is always
good I've got my stopwatch here to be
able to look at the time whenever I need
it and I'm gonna be able to do that
number three Lucas the son of a [ __ ]
himself the Eastern European hitman 47
copying [ __ ] that decides to
shoot you at every venture so here's the
dealio Lucas after 11:30 has a low
percent chance to be behind any door no
matter what after 11:30 he's gonna [ __ ]
you right in the butthole and there's
not a goddamn thing you can do about it
unless you want to try chance so with
that being said you need to get all your
purchases out of the way from the very
beginning and then just listen there's
multiple audio cues that let you know
he's in the area there's like honking of
a car outside there's steps on your
floor and then of course he is picking
the lock on your lock door which if it's
locked which it should be which you guys
are very good lock him down lock Lucas I
don't know if we can lock Lucas we got
to do that then you got to go in your
shower and hide for five minutes and
I've got my stopwatch to be able to
determine that as well
now the next threat would be the new are
the new or are the easiest he's got to
pay attention for it the dollmaker once
we go to the doll makers website he will
become active now I'm not 100% sure what
that involves but I've heard it's
actually fun so I haven't spoiled it for
me next up on the list of threats is
what else there was something else
important that I just remembered the
hacking yes
so they nerf the ability to initiate any
hack whenever you want so you can't do
that there's a cool-down so you can't
just constantly get hacked and get boss
going that way so my objective is to get
two VPNs
I want to get a motion scanner I want to
get hacked a bunch I have a list of
websites that are never available I have
a list of websites that are only
available at certain times so I've got
pretty much everything that I need and
we should be able to go through there
there's actually three versions of the
wiki there's three wiki's I don't know
how to get to each one but we got to get
through and we got to get to all the
codes as fast as we can
makes sense okay so for this one I'm
also gonna crank up the volume for you
guys so just be aware it's gonna be very
loud when there's a jump-scare but you
guys should be able to hear a bit better
all the threats that are gonna be coming
your way so I've got my audio cranked
way way way way up and I'm ready to go
Oh also I'm gonna be writing everything
down on actual paper I'm not gonna leave
anything up to chance when it comes to
my notes getting stolen or my notes
hacked I am writing everything down
physically so that I don't have to worry
about losing anything alright this is
the big fish this is the big kahuna this
is the big tuna we're gonna give this so
it's gonna be a lot of listening it's
gonna be a lot of quiet conversation
it's gonna be a lot of very patient
patient so just bear with me shut the
[ __ ] up Adam we don't need you give me
the goddamn free [ __ ] yes I know
and then let's turn this [ __ ] off and
we outie can I get up please
we're gonna turn out this light we're
gonna turn out the bathroom light we're
gonna turn out this light we're gonna
turn out that okay we're gonna go over
here we're gonna turn out this light
we're gonna turn out all the lights that
we don't need however we do need one
because if you have all the lights off
the Noir will kill you dead okay now
that we got that let's just double-check
that nobody's out here Anna let's get er
me apparently the VPN has been buffed as
well which means that we will get more
money from those than we did in the past
I'm not sure how much it's been buffed
but it's been buffed considerably now
what that means I honestly have no idea
but you know if that's actually gonna be
anything lock the paper I think I think
you've run out of things to possibly
lock I'm pretty sure that collectively
this this chat has covered every single
possible lockable thing and unlockable
thing that is ever in existence so I'm
not gonna lock chica that's horrible
horrible why would you do that oh no
that's so sad I can't lock the door yet
I'm not even back there's gonna be no
intelligent advice coming out of you
guys
there's gonna be everyone trying to come
up with new words someone's flipping
through a dictionary trying to think of
more things that they could possibly
lock alright anyway it's time to get
into it we don't need to worry about the
breather in the beginning phase because
he don't show up in fact I'm pretty sure
it's Adam that leads all these people to
my place but you know I can't prove it
so what's the point
let's tear this lose a package for Clint
so am I like really honestly truly I
want to get as much stuff as possible
before 11:30 because I've heard that
11:30 is when [ __ ] starts to go bad also
there's rumors that Lucas doesn't show
up until either you find the second wiki
page or the first key so if I don't find
a key right away then maybe I would be
able to get something you know tell me
out so I might try to get hacked a bunch
if I can do that I'm not 100% sure if I
can do that anymore
there's a cool-down of 70 seconds in
between each manual hack that you can
initiate so honestly who knows anymore
let's go e let's go e all right now you
guys remember what I need to do right
lock the door
pull it clack okay that's locked we're
good all right let's do this all right
power that on oh no wait what am i doing
god damn powered off powered off powered
off I forgot I need to actually place
the goddamn VPN I'm getting ahead of
myself
all right so supposedly this offers
slightly more money than it once did I'm
not a hundred percent sure about that
but it says it offers more money so I'm
going to believe it
but in all honesty this is not going to
be my main moneymaker my main moneymaker
is going to be being hacked although
there is a cool-down on that hopefully
it's not going to be the worst thing in
the world there we go that's a good spot
okay easy peasy what was that on that
door oh I thought I saw a pattern on
that door or something lock your
subscribers I don't think I can I don't
think I have the ability to do that
answer Adams call no I'm not gonna do
that either I've listened to Adams
drivel enough I don't need to listen to
any more of it lock the lock never
thought of that one
let's do this the time is now block okay
let's do this who's your all right so
we're gonna screw the notepad we don't
even need any notepad at all but what we
do need is we need to get online oh that
is generating a lot more dos coin it's
at ten eight six right now it's oh
that's much more okay that's much better
okay let's do this we're gonna get sky
break and we're gonna get the backdoor
hacks no whoa
oh crap I can't buy those I didn't mean
to click those anyway alright so we got
the backdoor hacks I'm going to get two
of those oh yeah that's way more VPN
money hell yeah okay so that's going on
there let's get e in E
let's get e in E to it come here you Shh
I'm up there we go alright home let's go
I don't know why I just said that I
might try to not get the first key right
away but you know it's just a race of it
against time okay
so I've a Satan is open not now
cheap surgery let's see cheap surgery is
never open cotton road is never open cry
[ __ ] is a good one okay cry [ __ ] it's
not a good one I'm not saying that these
are good ones I'm just saying it's one
that's probably you know oh that's not
fun pain screaming if woohoo
okay I thought I heard I thought I heard
something that might might have been a
like a lock-picking sound in that that's
that's no good at all okay all right I
hear like sounds and I don't like it
should be too early for literally
anything you don't even get hacked until
you get but oh my just hearin things
okay this doesn't even work
okay so that thousand no no all right
that's definitely a no-no yeah Lucas
well Lucas won't kill you if you get
codes you have to get codes to win Lucas
will activate if you get codes so mhm
we should probably be breaking Wi-Fi
let's actually just go ahead and start
breaking Wi-Fi because I want to get on
WEP as soon as possible
scan nope WEP scan all right deep dot
web is a no-go drone spy is yes okay
probe vq WPF 665 ki damn it one to a
thousand please okay source code nothing
videos I hear more noises and then I
remember there being and I don't like it
at all okay uh spy for me
uh no no nothing there yeah ah man for
some reason this game just makes me
absolutely nervous and I don't know why
sigh even that bad okay so that was a
no-go didn't find anything on that I
probably should have checked the source
codes on the other parts of it but
whatever I don't even know okay we've
only got five on crave is a yes I don't
know what do not break the nine means I
don't even know what the nine is the
okay all right then oh oh it's this one
okay this is fine that's a link I know
that nothing but the end source code
lots of gibberish lots of gibberish
nothing ok let's see if there's anything
in the gate okay nothing so far
a gate is open you have been warned
okay oh my mouse come on Mouse oh I need
to change Wi-Fi real bad okay let's uh
let's disconnect from that and move the
Wi-Fi movie movie okay all right connect
to this one let's see oh god I'm not
even on the right oh I can't I can't I
can't do it anymore okay whatever its
probes 6 9 6 9 3 D 5 9 7 o 9 6 9 3 is
the port I'll get back to it later ok
refresh that I'm losing it I've got all
this I've got all this planning and I've
got all these ideas and then I can't
even execute them because I'm just an
idiot most of the time okay 10 20 rolls
around that's when you can start being
hacked
okay source code is what I wanted to
look at the ground is dead under our
feet that doesn't help me there's
nothing here okay there's nothing okay
robe zj1 and b7p be 24,000 okay that's
gonna go we're good okay evidence locker
that is a good one I think anyway I mean
probably not good anyway but it is what
it is locked a hair lock system32 I'm
pretty sure that would break my computer
I don't think that's gonna help anybody
okay here we go
all right evidence Locker from and PGP
block that's not what I'm looking for
okay nothing there
whoa leaked image photos there's a
there's a mouse over lint clip leaked
what wait it says there's a mouse over
towards the bottom of it maybe it's
talking about the sidebar I don't know
oh yeah that's it okay that's all it is
oh here we go uh crack wait no I just
need to channel 12 port six three six
and god damn it god damn it oh come on
there there there Jesus twelve six three
six crack okay there we go all right
ah looks horrible this is horrible okay
this is horrible
all right um yeah it's too many pages on
this one all right
ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba purchase there's
anything over there access denied no
wallet oh wait that's obviously what
that is uh looks like nothing keep
saying that's it Oh return yeah whatever
okay it doesn't seem like there's
anything here all right we got a
password for this one
can I please expand this easier all
right so p WF one three eight two four
four five password is QWERTY forty-one
okay got that let's just hop on that
right now
see were t1 Connect okay so then the
police threat is slightly mitigated
which is nice all right
and we'll be safe on this for at least
another at least another 20 minutes or
so so at 10:45 when the game says 10:45
scream at me because I need to be out of
here all right okay let's
oh there's only one web on this one okay
that's fine come on let's go let's go
let's go let's go god that's a bug
that's a bug when you connect to a new
Wi-Fi if I hit the home button it should
go home it doesn't go home all right
family drug shop that's no father Donald
that's no forgive me yes that's a
yeparooni
okay we've got 13 das going we don't
have enough to buy another VPN we've got
until 10:30 to be able
by those VPNs which we can't do now okay
anything here
no I click the X button and then doesn't
see I want to [ __ ] my mother that's not
good okay all right
submit my confession all right I forgot
to burn wretch retrograde at the zone
that's my problem
that's way too loud you don't need to be
that loud thank you very much okay I
didn't find any codes that was a whole
bunch of useless way to go all right
that didn't do anything for me I've got
four minutes no I said 45 I've got way
more minutes than that I've got so many
minutes and you guys aren't gonna you
guys aren't gonna trick me
okay hail Satan that's a bad one my good
I think that's a good one yeah I
remember going to my gut that's good
lock the door the door is locked I can't
lock Lucas Lucas is impossible to lock
he's just too good there's no one that
can lock Lucas all right not seeing
anything okay that's no no PGP blocked
that's a no no shop okay fine
okay the process my good my good good
gut I'm sure your gut is great [ __ ]
[ __ ] scared the [ __ ] out of me
[Music]
give me some das goin baby oh boy this
one okay I got this okay there we go
there we go there we go there we go
there we go there we go there we go and
there we go got it I'm good [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you guys saw I had that that's a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] I had that alright error
loading cart nothing in here this is a
waste of time I [ __ ] had that I
[ __ ] had that I [ __ ] had that
[ __ ] [ __ ] alright number station
number station is available 32 it's
available now number station should be
available right now
Oh windows open that's good I can hear
now
like this let's just not do that let's
just have none of that let's just do
none of that
let's do none of that okay
none of that please none at all all
right
passports are us nope secure drop nope
sky Webb nope
than that Kano's is available in 45
thanks for visiting
that should be fine yeah no heck no heck
oooh no a whole lot of heck and a whole
lot of no oh not this one oh boy
well we're gonna be going through this
one forever aren't we probably all right
yeah you hear that nothing I think
that's just random traffic noise alright
alright
blink out index don't talk to me that
way
index index slidebar okay so the damnit
why does that happen every time I don't
want it to ah okay so this one goes to
slide but this one goes to bar I don't
know what bar is o'Barr is the big old
scan II do yeah yeah here we go and then
there's let me check the source code on
this one okay man I found a whole lot of
nothing and a whole lot of nothing so
far which is good it means that probably
probably uh we didn't check the source
code on that one there was probably
something in there it means that
probably Lucas isn't gonna come and
murder me right away which is always a
nice thing
okay don't click there well you know
what I wasn't gonna that goes to fake
main this goes to creepy if you hover
over that goes to creepy
alright you don't [ __ ] me this time
don't pump me this time do not [ __ ] me
this time good I got till 45 wait that
was a honk wait that was a honk wait
that was a honk ok I got to take care of
this first money that was a hawk but
that was a honk does that mean Lucas or
Z alright well that was a bust I don't
want to go through the rest of that now
cuz I got a bad feeling about this and
I'm gonna change the Wi-Fi just cuz I
can alright let's just disc actually
lets order
our second VPN we still have time for
that so let's go ahead and do that yah
yah yah and let's go ahead and as soon
as we get some more will get another
back to her hat cuz I only always want
to have two of those [ __ ] hell
yeah yeah yeah I'll get the Wi-Fi in
just a second everybody just hold on
hold on to your horses hold all your
horses on ok I think it'll still ship
even if we're on a different Wi-Fi so
let's go ahead and disconnect let's see
let's grab the dongle let's put it over
outside
hey let's go let's go let's go let's go
we're gonna connect we're gonna free
Wi-Fi no virus we're gonna scan we're
offline I said connect all right I can't
lock the honk how can i lock the honk
that doesn't even make any sense
all right probe our two AP SLK are
benign one to a thousand pretty please
okay we can keep moving we got 10
minutes until 10:50 10:50 that's we're
gonna do 10:50 ye ye ye 10:50 man I
haven't found a single key I I know it's
probably there's been keys but I just
haven't found it okay there was one son
at noce that's available not yet almost
the butcher is the butcher's fine okay
okay the butcher's not fine I thought
the butcher the butcher should be the
butcher should be the butcher should be
okay let's just say the butcher's not
the granddaddy yeah that should be fine
that's horrible but should be accessible
door okay all right the granddaddy I'm
your granddaddy uh [ __ ] whatever oh
here we go uh let's go seven four eight
six crack that bad boy okay as soon as
is done cracking I'm gonna go get my
package I'm pretty sure it's gonna be
out there and since it's before time
necessary it should be good enough okay
uh source code they said Lucas was at
two honks they said it was two honks for
Lucas not on a percent sure but might be
two honks I don't know okay I don't see
anything here all right that's no good
okay great all right that's good great
contact me don't want but didn't mean
double click that
nothing all right we got the password
let's go yes [ __ ] come on come on come
on I'm dropping everything Wi-Fi a
f-105d is one two three four five six
seven eight nine zero okay easy peasy
all right we're gonna disconnect for now
we're actually we're gonna shut down for
now and we're gonna get a yachty okay
we're probably fine we're gonna go get
that package Lucas should not be active
we haven't even gotten a single key yet
so we should be fine to get this and
then place it and then we should be fine
theoretically I'm not a hundred percent
sure about that but theoretically that's
how that do yeah I might even be able to
get a third one before 11:30 but I'm not
100% I don't know if there's anything
just shutting down my computer before I
go outside because if there's not then
I'm just being extra cautious and I
don't think that's the worst thing in
the world to be okay wherever any time a
door opens I'm doing
I didn't hear anything but you know I'm
just being extra extra extra cautious
okay it's been a minute I think it's
fine
yep 25 oh hi
okay huh not fine one two three four
okay there we go
all right we're fine this has been a
great adventure I'm real happy about how
all this went waste a lot of time here
probably won't be able to get my next VP
n at this juncture but you know super
happy super happy that I'm alive that is
very nice cannot complain about that one
man you know I'm probably getting
incredible shape going up and down all
these stairs like this that's that's
real nice real nice okay so we got our
second VPN and now that they buff the
VPNs it should give me a lot more money
but I don't know if it's actually going
to be incredibly because what else could
we possibly buy I would want a motion
sensor I really want a motion sensor but
I don't know if I'm gonna be able to get
one hate every door I hate every door
every single [ __ ] door I hate okay
grab you no one's here
leave let's try the fifth floor
hopefully that's gonna be okay I don't
know what time it is in game but it's
probably close to 11 by now nope not a
good place for it okay let's try in the
fifth try in the fifth floor oh [ __ ] me
that was my power going out on my floor
oh man that was scary I thought I didn't
expect anything to happen here and
that's why those sorry excuse me I have
a surge of adrenaline just then in there
let's keep trying there's nothing
nothing nothing I don't want to yell oh
I want to grow there we go green okay
now we go turn on our power before we go
up to our room and then we're gonna be
hunky and dory
it's got to be like 11 o'clock okay turn
power-on right there there we go open
that up there we go right so we've got 2
VPNs working at maximum efficiency
that's good
anyone in here come on I know in here we
are going to lock the door it's your
favorite moment everybody we locked the
door okay so we got this new Wi-Fi turn
this on we've got the password right
here turn it on all right
Wi-Fi one ad no come on now all right I
got this my brains working at maximum
pigeons one four one and four great easy
easy
six one I got it all right perfect I've
actually almost got enough for another
VPN so it looks like I may just have
enough time to get either a motion
detector or whatever have you
I've got it was there another one on
this area I'm not positive hmm oh no
this was the only one on this so I've
got until 11:20 I've got until 11:20 ok
the gray that that's one I know that
that's definitely one heard that
I haven't found a single goddamn thing I
bet thanks for visiting is gonna be the
entrance to the next the next the next
area I'm almost two percent positive
about that I almost don't want to find
out oh I can buy another VPN let's just
do that let's just do that you know cuz
why not
like literally why not and you know
actually before
before we get you know Fabra nacht we'll
just do that maybe by the time I run
down there it'll actually be there I
don't know I don't just like I don't
like just sitting around doing nothing I
[Music]
locked the door I swear I locked the
door I did I did I locked it look do you
think anyway um what I can do is I can
try to initiate another hack because
those happen every 70 seconds I can get
hacked again so I guess I should try to
do that I guess all right let's do
secure drop cuz that's definitely a
no-no let's get another backdoor hack so
if you just hit refresh on this I'll
probably get hacked
oh no wait no that's bad because I
remember this it's bad doing just this
because that will make the hacks more
difficult and make everyone else a lot
harder I think I remember that okay
let's not do that let's just go get our
[ __ ] because that's that's what I want
to do let's just go get our [ __ ] like
why not why wouldn't we go get our [ __ ]
it's time I bought another one let's
just go get it you know why not
okay let's why not I say why not I say
why not I say I don't know all right
okay there's still time in accordance
maybe it's eleven o'clock and not 11:30
but I'm pretty sure there's still time
to get this VPN and get it locked up I
may have time to get that motion scan or
two if I'm real quick about it because
these 3-peat VPN are gonna give me buku
bucks then again maybe I'm just maybe
I'm just fooling myself
me poop mark what what about me poop I
pooped my pants I pooped my pants
greatly when I play this game but I've
got other concerns than the poop in my
pants
didn't know that happened
didn't didn't know that happened Jesus
huh didn't know that still happened okay
I did not know that still happened I
guess that's good maybe that means you
can get away from the breather if you
just always time your deliveries to get
there when the thing happens or maybe
that's just gonna cover up the sound of
his audio cue cuz that's always a
possibility - all right let's get this
place the motion scanner let's do all
the [ __ ] let's do every of the thing
that we want to do yeah because I was so
worried that the breather was gonna like
be there but I wouldn't be able to hear
his footsteps because of the freaking
fan blades open Yuppie no one's here
grab you a bee okay go Louie I'm gonna
try on this floor first cuz I'm not a
hundred percent sure that it wouldn't be
here but uh just to make sure my
flashlight still works yellow just
yellow okay
all right up let's try the ups [ __ ] me
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] the UPS can I go in here
I can't go in there [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
okay floor 10 hey let's try floor down
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
I don't even know if there are any good
spots up here I just I don't know just
dad nothing better to do with my time
god there's nothing I've really [ __ ]
this I [ __ ] this alright we're fine it's
fine everybody you're all panicking over
nothing you're all panicking there's no
problems no problem
there's no problems there's no green
though god damn it there's no green up
here I can't get out there god damn it
well I just wasted a buttload of time
thank you for helping with that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
alright I guess we can try
I don't think floor seven is accessible
so we got to go all the way down like
floor two or something
can't go in there
for three really [ __ ] really really
give me something give me something give
me something man come on oh you're
really gonna be a dick aren't you oh
you're gonna be huge dick you're gonna
be the biggest the biggest dick oh
you're gonna be the biggest dick you
could possibly be getting going - you're
gonna be huge huge dick
Oh huge dick okay huge [ __ ] huge dick
[ __ ] huge Oh huge dick Oh big big big
weighty dick can't even can I even do it
out here Oh big floppy dick
Oh big poopy poopy dick oh there we go
finally god damn it okay
I don't even know if it's worth I think
three I'm gonna just leave it at three
cuz I don't I don't even know that was
not worth it no one okay that was not
worth it that waste so much time that
wasted an unbelievable amount of time
Luke is brought back up there because
I've wasted too much time outside of my
own apartment I don't even know if
that's possible but it seems like
something that'd be possible because
Lucas is an [ __ ]
okay great yay yeah I guess yeah if yeah
is the emotion that I can have right now
yay yay is what I feel all right lock
okay
we've got to have a lot of money by now
because I was gone for so [ __ ] long
all right connect Wi-Fi one two three
okay we've got until about 11:00 ish
we've got not if we've got barely any
money but that was not even worth it
okay whatever whatever whatever whatever
whatever whatever whatever whatever we
got 24 we got 24 and a half now let's
just go
let's get e out e let's do a movie this
single one single one okay I know
there's got to be something in thanks
for visiting but I just don't have time
the maddest dry the Magisterial to
secret cult let's go with that I guess
okay the Mantis dry look at the source
code we've got nothing enter you've got
enough for another VPN but I really
don't think it's gonna be worth it I
really don't think it's gonna be worth
it remember key nope nope let's go back
the last walk joined the Brotherhood
thought I heard something
okay we're fine okay blip BLAP the one
between and go I didn't even look at the
source code uh looks like a whole lot of
dick some Diddley on the side that's
awfully nice I'm gonna buy more of the
backdoor [ __ ] just because I can
backdoor hack yeah
ocean alert boy you have to buy motion
alerts that's crazy
okay we rock that is definitely one I
know that's one you there that's
probably also another one get the motion
sensor I don't have enough I the motion
sensor cost forty I have thirty at the
moment okay I don't see anything none of
these would be clickable this one is
okay we got a did we get enough [ __ ]
[ __ ] me oh okay in the dark in the dark
too dark dark dark it's good dark it
real good
sucks real good in the dark too they
appear in the dark do which is not ideal
but it is what it is
this is also bad because we just found
our first code so I didn't want to
venture out so Lucas might be active I'm
not gonna present sure that would be
crazy if Lucas was back in there somehow
okay okay
I wanted to buy another one of these oh
god damn and they need to connect again
I don't know how much cumulative time
I've had on this one Wi-Fi but I know
it's probably too much by a backdoor
hack just in case I don't even care
anymore okay
what was I doing I don't even know
anymore it's probably too late to even
go outside so I guess unless I want to
risk it unless I want to risk it oh yeah
that's right I already got what I needed
from this one a key to text okay to is
lowercase a five six e e4 d7
zero-nine-five see okay got it I got the
second coat I'm not even bothering with
any notepads I'm writing them down
manually manually okay that's good um we
need we've got thirty six we need two
I'm just gonna change Wi-Fi just because
I don't like not knowing how much time
I've spent in total on this single one
okay let's do this okay there we go
get back honey here okay scan
connected duty we've almost got 40
should we risk getting I don't like 3w
no w3 I heard of honk you read that honk
you guys heard the honk right it was a
single honk should be fine
[Music]
[Music]
3.5 that's all I get for that for my
trouble lock the door did I not lock the
door did I not lock the door right I
didn't lock the door oh that's why you
guys are here that's why you guys are
here that's why you guys are here you
guys catch me when I'm a stupid idiot
should I should I risk getting the
motion sensor yes I should I'm gonna do
it cuz I'm Way too behind I'm Way behind
on everything and frankly I just want it
to feel safe I just want to feel safe I
want to know it's there oh it's shipped
already wow that's that's [ __ ] fast
ok let's shut this down shut this down
let's shut this [ __ ] down let's go get
the motion detector we may die there's I
mean chances are low I've heard that
it's just a very low possibility it's
not guaranteed but you know we're going
for it anyway we're going for it we're
gonna go for it that is a bad idea the
breather
gonna get us we're gonna die de Lucas
Lucas is also gonna get us they're all
gonna get us we're gonna die this is
death is death but all the motion sensor
that's that's the thing is when was the
thing he he he
okay okay I just do that as a precaution
just in case cuz III don't trust myself
I've never actually heard what he sounds
like specifically so I don't know 100%
what is safe and what is not safe but we
still could die on the way back up if we
die on the way back up then I will say
big I told you so to myself so I told me
so mium so told me that I told me that
me and so do by the way if it ends up by
the end of this livestream that I don't
manage to beat this game I'm gonna
change the title to let's finish this -
let's not finish this ever because I
don't think I ever would okay Lucas
please just don't be there just to all I
asked Lucas all I asked Lucas just don't
be there that's all I ask don't be don't
be here we whoa okay so where's where's
the motion sensor where does that even a
pit where is the motion sensor appear
what oh here it is
okay all right let's find a place for it
I think at the the hall right right here
at the hall as good a place as any
there we go you know what that's
probably for the best
all right so now we know if anyone's
gonna come down the hall yay yay let's
go with the big yay
locker okay I'm gonna go with yay no
let's go with yay okay so I don't know
how far along we were in cracking this
code probably not oh there we go
okay let's go Channel 393 and crack
crack that bad boy oh let's get some
internet on duty we're not gonna have a
lot of time on duty but that's okay
because we're cracking it right now
which should be fine
okay how do I know motion sensor okay so
that should trip says green so should be
fine right found it okay so where's my
weird my pen go there it is okay so
Wi-Fi folder is three one five four
seven five got it okay we're going right
to that one filter three one four five
got it all right we're on let's get the
other one while we're doing this go home
please sister recipe it's just a recipe
it's just a recipe you father you follow
the recipe should be fine okay you there
I think you there is something nope you
there is apparently not something I
don't know why you there isn't something
but you there should be something is it
maybe oh it's not there available now
okay we just missed it alright so that's
just not available now okay let's probe
for n29 QN 54 z 9 go okay so the only
thing left to do is going into thanks
for visiting I think I can try to find
the other you know thing
no motion okay does a honk
there's just one hunk
I don't like that I don't like it okay
let's see what these have choose wisely
go to index index posture yeah I think
this one was the one it looks like
posture is the only thing okay we got
here
the only thing is this and goes to bar
which is the same thing that I did
before pretty sure anyway I want to get
back to that fake main because I last
time I did this I know that the fake
main led to something oh hi okay um
looking at this wall don't like that I
don't like that oh I don't like that I
don't like that I don't like that at all
[Music]
not here anymore great okay good good
good good good
and I'm pretty sure this one was just
yep just here which goes to slide to
this must lead to the second wiki I know
it must go I almost Oh what the [ __ ]
hang on what what what the [ __ ] whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
what the [ __ ]
yeah I don't think that was for me sorry
I went silent longer than I need to do
but I was just like this it's still
locked yeah there is a possibility that
there are police sirens not for me they
can go to other people and it's just
like a fake out so that's what that
could have been just a random fake out
which is fine totally fine totally fine
better safe than sorry right better safe
than sorry
every time better safe than sorry still
no motion alert don't emotionally come
on is it just not
oh I'm not connected that's right god
damn it okay god I gotta get back to my
other page three one five four seven
five go connect I'm probably gonna get
hacked as soon as I get into this okay
now scary very scary don't know why we
needed to go through all that okay one
goes to creepy woman goes to fake main
that's right what was that sounded
totally fine I'm pretty sick I knew it I
knew it I knew it I knew it I knew it I
knew it I knew it I knew it
[Music]
I knew it I knew it I knew it be true it
was good of a dream okay easy I got 17
[ __ ] yeah baby
[ __ ] yeah baby okay I'm gonna be able to
bother good software soon okay
so there's got to be some thing here BG
fake main don't talk to me link out to
black twas a clever ruse
let's go - don't talk to me I don't
remember what that is probably bad
probably very very bad okay we got a
password
it's just system oh [ __ ] not again oh
okay totally fine I hate this favorite
thing my least favorite thing least
favourite thing I don't know if there's
any actual danger from the power
government I really don't I really don't
know if there's any actual danger I mean
maybe maybe Lucas could get in that way
but I don't think so [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] let me just lock my door I don't
like that [ __ ] don't like that [ __ ] at
all hmm
okay fine thank you for [ __ ] off okay
just about to write down I keep losing
my pen I don't know I put it over there
okay sudden link sudden link is system
okay but we should be fine on filter for
at least a little bit longer three one
five yeah why why take the risk I say I
say Suddenlink 'let's
a Suddenlink right system okay
eventually we'll need the the
higher-quality one but let's go back to
don't talk to me oh no not this oh I
already been here that's right I've
already been here we need to go to twas
a clever ruse right I think so
yeah we need to go to twas a clever ruse
no not that not I just did that [ __ ]
this don't talk no what wait that oh
there it is god damn it off I'm a
[ __ ] idiot
I keep [ __ ] this up okay we need to
go here towards the clever ruse that's
what we need to go to okay okay so one
of these let me look at the source code
first okay that goes to numbers that
goes to face when goes to face one goes
to numbers one goes to link click index
no we don't know go to index we're not
going to index we're going to face
there's also one that goes to numbers
what's numbers have we done numbers yet
I don't know what numbers would be also
where is that it's somewhere in here
it's this is saying it's somewhere in
here right before in here there there
right right there there we go
got the numbers I don't know what
numbers is what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
Oh God okay one goes to but they all go
to black creepy and index uh the first
one is okay let's just go the first one
I think that's the only one I haven't
been to I've been too creepy that one's
the creepy one no that's creepy okay
thank you for that didn't need that you
guys keep an eye on that motion sent
here we go this is what I was looking
for I don't know what that noise was
that was definitely a thing god damn and
just led back to here okay fine
uh the only thing I could think of is
face I don't know what face is and I
don't want to know what face is I'm
gonna change the Wi-Fi soon don't worry
I'm gonna go back to the other one I'm
good oh god it's this [ __ ] alright
baby shrimp that is that all it does
just goes back to baby shrimp god dammit
well then what is there a point to this
do you guys know what do you guys know
if there's a point that that must lead
somewhere it has to it has to lead
somewhere huh we're gonna has to write
slide numbers index index face
let's go back to numbers I guess I don't
know
there's nothing here either I haven't
found a code in any of these I don't
know any of these it doesn't make any
sense this is a big waste of time I
don't know anymore I just don't know I
don't think yeah I don't think it's
anything I'm out of here
I've got almost a hundred Doss going by
the way but I never want to leave my
apartment anymore
maybe I have to okay let's see what we
can buy better VPNs the key q that would
be nice
we need to get this next level of
breaking why didn't I just go to wpa2
why didn't I just do that why did I
waste money on whatever barely sat down
buddy
[Music]
fifty-two I've got so much money great
I've got oodles and oodles and
Kaboodle's of money what am I gonna do
with it probably waste it probably might
give me this give me this [ __ ]
you mean this should give me a back door
hack do I need this audio alert I don't
want that audio alert I don't want it at
all uh what else could I buy is it even
possible what would even be the point
okay you know what I'm going to do is
I'm going to close out of this and I'm
try the the other braking mechanism I've
never done the other brake so this might
be harder than you know I've tried I
don't know help okay scan inject
inject I don't even know what that means
all right um lo P disk I don't even know
what that means what does a low P disk
do I don't know okay help inject channel
what okay I guess inject is what I want
to do inject let it scan again number of
injections what does that mean okay
in jack j-t GW g z1 f JY channel 7 let's
try a hundred all right what time is it
also can I try one of these other what
time is it 12 2000 waist here you there
you there I can go to you there I think
I think I can go there now yeah nothing
on the motion sensor okay you there I
see very little let's go to the source
code
that was a hunk okay
oh the networks offline oh wait did I oh
I oh so I can't send too many requests
or else it's going to ah that's a
problem okay that's a problem okay um
well I have no idea
okay let's try let's try FBI
surveillance van with only 50 attempts
channel 1 9 8 III CP x 7 5 f let's try
that I don't know if that's gonna work
also is there anything in here can't see
you've come to the wrong place we are
not equal in your skull will be open for
his pleasure great there's nothing here
there's nothing here ok there's nothing
here god damn it push there's nothing
there it's a whole lot of nothing it's
it's a whole lot of nothing that's all
I've got
see did that work
I don't know if it works whatever I
don't think it worked
a little time - okay well I just okay I
[ __ ] that up I didn't know I [ __ ]
that up but apparently I [ __ ] that up
I don't know how that works yet oh god
damn it
okay let's try III remember I was almost
- lets go w WEP home
god damn it close it open it we need to
get back on the other one WEP scan we
were close to d5 9 709 which should be
more than enough for now anyway again I
don't know if it's cumulative time it
might be cumulative time okay um crack
vq WP f 6 6 5 ki channel 8 6 9 3 go baby
go I can hide in the closet I'm well
aware of that but I've everything I've
read said hiding in the closet is a
[ __ ] terrible idea like the worst
idea you could possibly have okay got it
lacrosse look cross while I'm on this
I'm gonna try to crack the other one
nothing that's gonna do me any good but
I'm gonna try to crack the other one
we're gonna get out of this we're gonna
go WPA okay scan okay
sorry this is new territory for me I
have no idea what's going on I'm just
trying my best
inject 78 GLB why I and why Channel four
let's try 50 again and then we'll give
that some time in between that and the
next one we're on lacrosse we're good
let's go home okay we'll wait a second
for that I've got 139
I've got 139 bullshit's still no motion
sensor all right Ave Satan have a Satan
30 okay almost time for Ave Satan cheap
surgeries no Konrad's no deep web is no
family drug shop no no hail satan also
no passports are us also no secure drop
no sky web no Thanatos that's at forty
five ok so in one minute I'll be able to
go to another one let's try this again
[Music]
the numbers sign out of code I'm not on
a percent sure I believe you and I
wouldn't know how you would be able to
tell ok that's a problem oh my god how
much money that I get from them a lot
apparently I don't even know it was a
lot though I'm so scared
but I'm pretty close to getting the key
cue so that's nice then help I guess
alright um I need more of these oh god
it's starting to do the hovering thing
ok did that work no let's try again ok
let's just get a bunch of these man
those hacks are gonna get tougher and
tougher
I'm just buying a bunch I don't know why
hmm okay I I think I think it's fine I
think it's totally fine I think it's
fine I think it's fine okay we can go to
Ave Satan now I think yeah we can go to
Ave Satan or should be able to uh here
we go
this looks like a thing okay we've got
nothing here none of these are clickable
right I know what you mean okay it's
some kind of message board they don't
know haha reply reply I don't think any
of these are clickable you [ __ ] dude
yeah you talking about me you're
probably talking about me I don't think
any of these were clickable yeah it
doesn't look like anything was clickable
yeah okay now let's go home oh let's try
some more I didn't see anything if you
guys saw something I didn't see anything
the other side needs a motion alert can
you get into the elevator the elevator
doesn't work work it doesn't work it
just doesn't work okay whatever totally
fun um now it's 34 I have no idea I
really have no idea I I don't know what
else to do because I'm just I'm just
floundering here I I've got no I've got
no other network that I can get into I
want to get into these other ones but
apparently I can't
I mean I've still got time left on this
one this is a freshly cracked once
okay that was weird okay I'm gonna run
out of time at this rate cuz I need to
find some goddamn keys nobody in here
okay lucky okay have I injected into
this thing yet no go connect back to
this and passwords across but I don't
have forever on this I know I don't have
forever on this thing so I got to get
moving I got to get into this thing
check more it's just gonna go offline
it's all it's gonna do
Lucas is not lock-picking my door there
I must have missed something
all right I'm gonna go back to you there
but I don't think is it time for you
there no I think I missed the I missed
the time for you there yes not quite
time for you there it's not you their
time yet yeah uh but but it is time if
it's 30 to 34 your data obvious Aiden no
I need to get in fanat knows I know I
need to get in that that comes at 45
okay this is come on keep going good god
I need to get to fanat knows that's the
only one left on my entire list that I
don't have access to right now I've got
243 daus coin I'm hoping
okay I think I think we're Gucci I think
we're Gucci
I think we're Gucci I don't know if the
motion sensor went off that may have
been steps on another floor it's always
possible that was just another floor's
footsteps which which is a thing that
can happen like it can be
it could not be me but I waited the five
minutes anyway so even if it was or was
not him definitely uh yeah definitely
definitely didn't want to risk it if it
was so it's it's like not worth not
worth anything if it's just gonna be a
problem like that okay so as soon as I
get this cracks I need to go there it is
now 51 I can go to Thanatos so I'm gonna
see where that goes I think that's the
last one in this area that I have yeah
I'm not going through the peep hole
because he could still be there I could
hear him he could still try to pick my
door but I'm not gonna know how to risk
it you know I'm just not gonna risk it
oh hello fan and nose like you
god dammit there's nothing here
it's nothing it's just nothing god damn
it I found one key I found one good God
just [ __ ] one let me in this goddamn
oh oh oh it's ready to crack okay that's
that's good why can't okay all right um
cut the I can't to crack
wait no channel for crack that was it
right crack all right we're cracking in
cool cool easy all right
not easy but did it alright so once I'm
on this one I shouldn't have to worry
about the time for much longer and and
I'm pretty close to getting there we go
password is Harley got it okay
password is Harley for de da three
chicks it's Harley okay let's just go
ahead and connect that da three chicks
all right we're in okay we're in and
this should be a good connection so this
should be nice and fast hopefully not
that it's any different than what it was
but okay that worked out I can't believe
it worked out I'm gonna go ahead and try
to get the other one going other than
that yeah brutal underground no red
triangle no the hall no the butcher is
the butcher one the butchers one right
[Music]
3:9 well that was that was criminally
easy why was that one so easy why was
that so easy all right whatever inject
hmm seven vx6 k3s why 750 I didn't check
all the great you're right I did not
check all of the gray I didn't check all
the gray what Oh
I said fifty all right well let's try
something else then let's try thirty at
a time man I did I did so much on the
other one I just assumed that was a safe
number
Oh rizz qq5 5dw try thirty I guess yeah
I did not check all of the gray you are
a hundred percent right I did not that
is where I need to go okay we are the
gray will you walk in the shade yes I'm
ready to walk in the shade okay you
ready to begin no I'm not alright
Latsis has got to be one in here running
at time I think the game over it games
over at like 4:00 a.m. source code link
out no return the webpages do seem to be
loading a lot faster which is awfully
nice I do like that that is really cool
alright it's really cool and also I'm
very close to getting my key Q that'd be
nice man the crazy thing is like I've
been I've been looking at every single
like every single source page every
single like bullshitter e I've tried
man I've tried everything okay nothing
there all three Ananas nothing nothing
nothing nothing give it nothing [ __ ]
nothing just a whole lot of nothing it's
just nothing god damn it where is
everything
I'm crazy I I heard something that
sounded like footsteps I wasn't I wasn't
a hundred percent sure yeah are you guys
saying I need to move the the motion
sensor to green so so who's red here is
there like a better place for it I don't
think there's a good or bad place for it
I think it's always gonna be red I think
you guys are just I think you guys are
just herd mentality inking I'm pretty
sure this was totally fine where it was
I'm almost a hundred percent positive
this was totally fine where it was yeah
yeah there you guys are you guys are
going bonkers this is always gonna be
red yeah you guys are going bonkers
yeah you guys are going bonkers don't go
bonkers on me dog don't listen to the
herd that's what you got to do you're
just gonna no no no no there's no green
area for it there is no green area for
it that's not how that one works you
guys are crazy
you're crazy you're out of your mind you
guys are crazy crazy you guys are out of
your mind get back in your mind okay cuz
it says right here it says it's
connected it's fine it's fine it's fine
it's totally fine you guys you guys are
crazy cuz it's crazy both sides I'm not
gonna buy another one I don't want to go
outside I'm gonna save up I'm gonna get
that key I'm gonna get the key code
thingy that's gonna have whoa is there
hope there is okay I had a funny feeling
about that hmm
someone's at my door I don't want to say
hi but I don't want to be rude either so
let's leave it at that
no I'm not gonna what would be the use
of its in the apartment if it's in the
apartment it's not gonna do me any good
cuz I'm in the apartment you guys are
crazy this is worse than your locking
obsession now it's like move the mood
you guys alright umm I don't know what
I'm doing I don't know what I'm doing
anymore I'm just waiting I'm just
waiting just [ __ ] waiting getting no
months no money no codes no no nothing
Oh is there any other one that needs to
be the butcher I could've sworn I've
been to the butcher before Skyy web
doesn't work secure drop doesn't work
password doesn't work
hail Satan does not work father Donald I
don't know maybe these got changed up
you know I should at least try them I
guess nope that one doesn't work they
don't work
Kahn Road I bet that worked in the other
one that worked in the other one but I
think it works here at least I got a
fast connection
[Music]
memory okay fine four five four five
seven three not hard 16 that's all I get
that's all you're gonna give me 16 16
smackers that's it fine God every
[ __ ] time oh I didn't know I locked
my door I did what what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] my flashlight what what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] it's
extra dark what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
all my flashlights out of batteries I
guess
those are my flowers lies dead I guess
my flashlights dead I think why why why
I don't know anymore
I don't have the code [ __ ] I don't
have enough money I'm trying to go to
all these fake sites that don't work
don't work I don't know family drug shop
I didn't lock the door you're right I
didn't lock the door good god
good [ __ ] god I'm gonna die how I die
is how I die huh ah
hater father Donald oh that lady's work
hail Satan
and I used to internet being this fast
my heart is going a million miles I'm
not not okay
my flashlight is completely bunk my
flashlight is gone I don't know how I
must have accidentally had it like
enabled when I didn't want it to be and
I really [ __ ] up
I definitely [ __ ] up come on go
[ __ ] go go [ __ ] go [ __ ] go it's
[ __ ] impossible that one is just
[ __ ] impossible [ __ ] I'm gonna go buy
something because [ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm
gonna go buy another motion alert now
that's gonna do me anything [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] impossible it doesn't
[ __ ] work
it wasn't pisses me off to no end it
doesn't game developer doesn't [ __ ]
work god damn it it's like what what
didn't the [ __ ] are you out of your
goddamn mind like your minigames don't
even make logical sense to be one versus
the other it's just [ __ ] circle
jerking [ __ ] I mean I'd be fine if
it's hard and time pressure but it
doesn't [ __ ] work
there's nothing to buy there's nothing
to buy there's nothing to buy
I got no codes I've got no way into the
wiki reload my game and get my
flashlight back that's not a bad idea
it's not a bad idea
let's try that one shut up I don't want
to help you no I'm not gonna calm down
it's [ __ ] broken it's broken
I it's like I know what to do
I can click the [ __ ] buttons but they
even the timer even the timer doesn't
make sense because the timer resets
every time you get something successful
but then suddenly it's like doodlee
doodlee do nope and it's like what it
does there's no visual cues for it the
clicky doesn't work when you want it to
clicky why is it that why isn't the
bridge between them the clicky ones too
clingy this tiny [ __ ] button is
[ __ ] stupid it's just stupid it's
just [ __ ] stupid where am i where am
i what am i okay I've got my flashlight
back I guess where am I
okay this is before I lost my money but
this is before I I did anything in this
[ __ ] ah at least I'm on day chick
okay alright let's do this inject from I
was doing a p r z QQ 5 5 zw6 try 30
sorry I got a little heated there I'm
fine now I'm fine I'm fine I am fine
what am i doing I don't even I don't
even remember anymore what I'm doing
sorry I'm fine let's go to you there
someone said that there was something in
the ASCII art but I doubt it but you
never know with this [ __ ] okay seems to
be a whole lot of nothing no codes
nothing in the source code god [ __ ]
damn it nah there's nothing here
nope nothing seems to be there this is
annoying right it's just annoying like I
know what to do and you guys know the
one thing I hate the most about games is
random chance and I'm not saying this
game is overwhelmingly with random gems
because there's a pattern and there's
stuff that you need to do but I have one
code one code just one and I swear I've
been going to these like as much as I
possibly can I've been doing this as
faithfully to what I what I think is the
correct solution as much as I can and it
seems to just go nowhere for me and I
don't know why like I don't know why I
can't log in here there's nothing to do
I'm stuck going back through the same
things that I've done before like mmm I
want to win I want to win and in any
game in any game if you do the right
stuff if you do the right thing you
should win that's the way that it should
work right like it's just my
understanding that that is generally how
games should go it doesn't matter
it's hard if you get good at the game
you will eventually win right that's not
how this game works well the only thing
I can hope for at this point is to get
the is get the the code key ding dong er
and then hope for the best
I've also think I've been through pretty
much everywhere you b0f e ub 0 f e Simon
Says I'm a smart e FP z FP Zeke you've
made the bunny 51 that's good money
thank you for the money
I appreciate the money okay still not
enough still not enough so let's keep
testing fate I guess tempting fate sorry
I don't know my hallway bullshitter
enabled I just need a little more money
that's all I need just a little more
money and then I'll get the code cracker
oh yeah I should make sure my door is
locked cuz I haven't honestly haven't
maybe when I saved it yep it was not
locked
alright let's keep trying this
alright there we go another sweet fresh
hack already done to myself
memory easy are I got this are F Q a w
RFQ aw day a Z Y Desi u n K V G UNK
that's all I get
[ __ ] you man Oh God alright I guess
we're close to getting it we just need
about ten more daus coin well I'm not
gonna tempt fate and try to get it
through that I'm just gonna wait we're
very close to getting that so yeah let's
just go through this again try to find
it as best we can on crave do not break
the nine Blackwater we will not stand
for it every firstborn
I am the Lord there's nothing but the
end and there was nothing in here I
swear I've been through every one of
these maybe the game just doesn't like
me because I complain about this so much
baby maybe that's all it is I mean I do
love to go on a good rant I really do I
really really do but alas I sometimes
put my foot in my mouth and maybe the
game hears me because there's a
microphone here maybe the game
developers just don't like me that's
definitely a distinct possibility I
would I would believe that very much
all right evidence Locker is the only
thing that I can that was two honks that
was two honks that was a honk honk do I
go now that was a honk honk those two
honks that was a honk honk you know what
I'm just gonna this is
okay here's my good nun trim now if I
got in the shower before before he
started baking the lock does waiting
five minutes help me because what if I
come out maybe I [ __ ] up
it's always possible you guys are the
litter own website there was a link that
would get to the second wiki page okay
I'm gonna go back to the drone website
but for those of you are saying you can
get more going from refreshing down
pages that was patched out and it makes
it harder and harder to get through the
game if you do that that's an old
strategy as of Tuesday of this past week
that strategy was passed patched out in
other words I'm smart you're a [ __ ]
idiot so there we are okay so my time or
somehow stopped I'm thinking
so I think we're fine and I know we're
running out of time
we've been bumper knocked this whole
time I don't even know if there's enough
time to get through the rest of the game
we were able to get all of these keys so
I'm gonna risk it I'm gonna go I don't
want to see what happens
okay we're fine we're fine i I I had a
funny feeling like going I knew she
going into the shower was a bad idea uh
god damn it okay so we're gonna go back
we're gonna go to the Oh God we're not
connected god damn it
okay hardly we've got a little more time
on this particular Wi-Fi I know that
we're gonna go back home we're gonna
look we've got enough for the code key
thing let's just get that before we get
hacked again let's let's go ahead and
just get that cuz I want it the key q
installing the key q that's gonna take
[ __ ] forever but that's okay we're
gonna go to the drone spy apparently one
of you guys spotted the link to the
other wiki there so I'm gonna trust you
on this one
looking in the source code doodlee
doodlee do spy for me videos I don't see
anything there so let's go to videos
we're going to videos let's inject more
code wallet boss coin here no that's
just the wallet that's not it
let's go to spy for me I was on another
oh come on
I was not on it for that long
there was a WPA one [ __ ] you
there was a [ __ ] wb1 I had fifty
[ __ ] minutes with that are you
[ __ ] kidding me
[Music]
are you [ __ ] kidding me
that was WPA one that's supposed to be
50 [ __ ] minutes on that [ __ ] I
had that [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you game
and like my computer wasn't even on when
that was happening
that's so [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] shut
the [ __ ] up game I need to rant about
this for a bit okay here's the [ __ ]
thing that's [ __ ] [ __ ] number one
pure and simple number one I wasn't even
on line half that time I [ __ ] just
unlocked one [ __ ] thing
one WBA one I was fine on that for fifty
[ __ ] minutes that's what it's
supposed to be and number two [ __ ] you
game developers I'm gonna [ __ ] say it
because this game is [ __ ] this game
is [ __ ] [ __ ] and [ __ ] stupid
and it's broken and your hack games are
inconsistent it's just [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't care who
knows it it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
all right let's go again
[Music]
maybe maybe because I'm not wrong I was
not on that network for 50 minutes at
all not even consistent not even
consecutively 50 minutes but not even
just 50 minutes by themselves because I
legitimately I was not because I kept
turning the computer off I must have
been in in that for a maybe like 10 15
minutes of actual computer online time
which is ridiculous
because if it counts time when the
computers off that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
that is just pure and simple broken
[ __ ] and just absolutely asinine why
would anyone do that that is just stupid
because if that's the case then it would
be counting time that I'm connecting the
network right now even though I'm not I
disconnected before I went unless
there's a difference between shutting
down the computer and disconnecting from
it which even so if that's the case
that's even more [ __ ] because I shut
down why the [ __ ] would I still be
connected to it
just [ __ ] [ __ ] across the board
is [ __ ] [ __ ]
pure and simple [ __ ] [ __ ]
now I'm so mad I'm so angry I'm not even
gonna be scared by this game anymore
that's always what happens no [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up who is that I shut the
[ __ ] up shut up shut up shut up you're
dumb and stupid you're dumb and stupid
you're dumb and stupid you're dumb and
you're stupid oh my god alright let's
just do this again all of my [ __ ]
passwords [ __ ] garbage now I'm gonna
give this one more try and if it doesn't
work then it's dumb and I believe the
game is stupid it's stupid and it's dumb
this game dumb and it is stupid stupid
and dumb here we go a stupid dumb here
we go stupid and dumb dumb this game is
dumb and it is stupid and dumb and
stupid it's dumb and stupid dumb is
stupid yeah look at that it's not a
stupid oh let me how to pick a pot right
there for him advice reform that's right
before oh my god someone else I get the
ban shot the [ __ ] up great good job you
got yourself banned
if anyone's spamming that copy/paste
[ __ ] don't don't don't bother it's
outdated information number one and also
number two it's just stupid okay let's
do this zero day we're offline let's
connect to this bad boy let's turn the
is there really no option between loud
and I'm just gonna turn the sound off I
didn't even know turning the sound off
was an option on
thing okay sky break let's disconnect to
that well get that we'll get the other
libraries for the other stuff soon and
we're going we are into it all right Ave
Satan that's available not now bathroom
cams not available now her no bathroom
cams not work borrow my daughter that is
something available now yes alright
let's do this let's do this Leroy
Jenkins Leroy Jenkins oh no a horrible I
don't see anything on here right now
let's look at the source code high
bidder deposited happy bidding d1 bid
anything that doesn't seem to work okay
seems like a big old nope on that one
let's probe 94 fq j BS n8 g 8 and 1 mm
blur t please nope that's oh wait sorry
what are thousand pretty please thank
you
alright I don't see anything else on
this it seems like this is the only page
on this front so I'm gonna put this as a
big old nope that's a big old nope click
the image no the image was not clickable
or maybe it was and I just know I would
have noticed if it was I might go back
to that just in case I might go back to
that but for now I think it was fine all
right bug friendly I know that's a 1
that's a horrible one but that is a 1
lock the door you are correct your
corrects your crooks
you are correct I'm stupid lock the door
ok liddie liddie
ok come on find that find that find that
bad boy alright we've got we've got
linked out to join we've got a link out
to noid what does that do
wait where's that password what noid was
annoyed mean PGP key that doesn't help
anybody I don't know what this is but
that's not what I'm looking for okay
OOP there we go all right let's do
channel eight 7:30 and crack that bad
boy
crack that soldier boy okay what is this
is this important probably not
hmm doesn't seem important
probably very not important no plug-in
ID found whatever this is I don't think
that's anything of use no I don't think
so all right going home I think we're
gonna be safe for a good while we also
need more of those backdoor hacks at
least two of these all right cheap
surgery that's no cotton road as a No
cry [ __ ] is a yes I'm pretty sure
anyway cry [ __ ] is horrible very bad
very bad very bad very bad sign in has
something but that's probably all it is
I don't think there's gonna be anybody
in the initial phase of this game I'm
pretty sure it's gonna be nothing all
right login key blabbity blabbity login
nope nada nada nada
oh mercury okay d5 nine 709 mercury II
got it cool got it lock the developers I
wish I wish alright let's go ahead and
connect to that actually mercury connect
got it got it got it got it let's go
again
Ardi 590 709 on my notepad I just see
the shadow of a giant dick on here I
have no idea why there's just no pens
it's like the outline of a hard pressed
dick alright it looks like it says it
looks like there's something at the end
of it but it must just mean the sidebar
here because I don't see anything else
here sidebar yeah
was there another network on this
network I think there was there must
have been right
yes there was let's probe 9852 for I
know for I da ki one to a thousand
pretty please pretty please if I asked
nicely are you gonna be nice to me
I bet you're not all right we've got
nothing nothing we got purchase no
schooling that nothing nothing nothing
yeah the only ones are the purchased
keys okay so let's just click on that
let's crack this bad boy eight on just
five we will crack you and we will get
joined this one in about twenty minutes
fifteen minutes we'll give it 15 minutes
now wallet found nothing here return
just goes to index I'm pretty sure
that's gonna be nothing schema.org is
last web web page yeah I don't think
this is anything all right nothing here
perfect
easy-peasy I love it one it's simple and
easy we don't have to worry about there
being anything because there's
absolutely nothing and we found the
password alright so SS Wi-Fi is no lucky
all lowercase one that got it all right
hot burners hot burners is not
illuminati is not legion is no little
friends is not available yet but it will
be mortal masks that is there that's
when I remember mortal masks yeesh
alright okay yucky yucky hey Kiki I
thought I heard something I don't think
I don't think there's anything to hear
yet okay nothing on here nothing by the
looks of it okay let's just go order
okay Windows not even open yet should be
fine alright let's get out of this this
alright immortal Mass $75.00 cone and
baby here no there nope okay how do I do
it I don't want to know but let's find
out shall we
okay nope
bah bah bah okay looks like absolutely
nothing so we got nothing on that one so
that one's bub kisses well we need to
change Wi-Fi in about 10 minutes
we can start being hacked now by the way
being hacked is now a threat a very very
reasonable threat red triangle is not
available yet secure drop is not a thing
share your genitals that's probably a
thing yep that's a thing no no no don't
like this one oh don't like this one ooh
nope don't like nope don't like that one
we got a whole lot of nothing yep that's
gross and it's [ __ ] disgusting all
right we're gonna just pretend that
never happened okay all right
that was one snuff portal he's not one
Saint Louis Arch is one is it just the
theory behind the power of the st. Louis
Arch okay our window is now opened
that's good now I can hear things come
on give me something
oh you will die soon get out of the
country Oh it'll emit a signal from the
earth core destroying American
populations I've never heard of that
before I've honestly never heard I've
never seen this webpage before
I'm ready I'm ready for it bring it on
st. Louis Arch please bring it on I'm so
ready it's like the halo ring I'm not
anymore I've calmed down I'm much better
all right let's okay what do we got here
built and [ __ ] duck of the hoozy what's
it the arch has no links no clickable x'
no nothing okay go back one cuz there's
more to this website anybody here and
nope the answer is a Zippo all right the
aliens I want to be Annunaki the
Annunaki okay all right
which the government relocated to the
Egyptian tech that's wonderful oh hello
friend ah you look you look real fun
okay thank you I know a web site called
the gray is that what this is about okay
nope okay the Annunaki didn't help us at
all yeah no I knew knock he definitely
didn't help me all right I need to
change Wi-Fi soon so I might as well
combo that with going to get my package
but let me see why I will die first
nope nothing yet all right magnetic
fields of their own will not kill a
human of the discharges elated radiation
bird leave the continent before a
mission
ok I don't want to owe nothing an
entertaining read nonetheless very
entertaining but alas I am a disconnect
and then I'm gonna turn off because
that's apparently how I have to do this
alright anybody here ok I'm out anybody
there nope ok good good let's go for it
let's go get our package let's go hi
guys
hotae whadda hobo oh babe Oh boho bum ha
ba dingo bingo have a flim be dimbo oh
all right everybody calm your collective
tits I've got this all under control I
know what this game is trying to pull up
on me I shall not let the world drag
across my eyes I know exactly what I'm
doing and if Lucas tries to fuchal duck
me well I'll just squeeze his head in
between my thighs until it explodes like
a watermelon and that's the only
punishment that he deserves nothing
better nothing worse all right I heard
that I heard that I heard that I heard
that that was - OH
oh my god are you go my god are you I
don't know how the [ __ ]
[Music]
that was my fault
that was my fault I should have been
more pre-emptive about the clicking
I think actually I think what happened
was I accidentally right clicked which
I'm willing to bet tried to get me up
from the door that's what I'm almost
positive that's what they did now cuz I
feel a strong surge through with my
middle finger shut up
oh yeah that's definitely what I've
accidentally right clicked which would
have got me up from the door and then he
would have burst in because I'm pretty
sure he like I'm pretty sure I saw that
and I clicked in time I think I just
pressed the wrong button so that's my
fault
but I'm done I'm done I'm not gonna play
you I might try again at some point but
god damn this [ __ ] game so hard I
mean immediately that last desk totally
my fault that was totally my fault I'm
almost 100% positive I right-click to
stay left click for some reason but
that's all for now so thank you
everybody someone for watching I might
be streaming later on Twitch I've been
playing tons and tons of gotta warn
50/50 mode on for tonight I don't know
if I'm gonna stream god of war just cuz
it's so fun and just like a nice
personal thing but before I do any of
that I have to go see a movie I'm gonna
go see a movie with Amy I'm gonna have a
fun day it's gonna be super cool so
thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you for watching this stream hit
that super-sweet subscribe button if you
want to be the coolest person on earth
ring that goddamn Bell if you want to
know whenever I upload a video or
whatever I don't know do whatever you
want it's your life I don't know if
it'll make you cooler or not but hey
there's always a chance if you hit that
button then your your respective I don't
know individual wealth and/or penis will
grow in measurably and it'll be great so
thank you everybody so much for watching
you guys have a lovely night I will let
you know if you want to know I stream on
twitch twitch TV slash markiplier follow
me there you'll get notified one of
their ever go live I just kind of do it
whenever I feel like it so thank you
everybody again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye bye guys
bye